le médecin l'a tendue à ses parents
et a dit en se basant sur son pénis,
« C'est un garçon. »
Elle a toujours su que c'était faux.
Les années ont passé et les émotions qu'elle ressentait
et gardaient en elle n'ont fait que grandir,
et elle a su qu'il fallait le dire à sa famille.
Et quand elle l'a fait, ça ne s'est pas très bien passé.
Ses parents ont dit : « Non. Tu n'es pas une fille.
Tu n'as pas été élevé comme ça. On ne sait pas à quoi tu penses.
Va-t'en. »
Anne s'est alors retrouvée à la rue et dans des foyers pour sans-abri,
et c'est là qu'elle a commencé à se droguer et à boire
pour oublier la douleur en elle.
Elle m'a parlé de ses séjours à l'hôpital et en désintox
pour essayer d'arrêter,
et des professionnels de soins et des médecins
qui n'utilisaient pas son nom féminin ou les pronoms corrects.
Ça la blessait.
Vous voyez, durant mes études pour devenir thérapeute,
on ne m'a pas appris à travailler avec des patients transgenres.
Je ne savais pas du tout que j'allais travailler avec eux.
Mais plus j'ai travaillé avec Anne et d'autres patients comme elle,
plus j'ai vu ma mission évoluer :
il fallait que je m'assure qu'on réponde aux besoins médicaux
de la communauté transgenre.
Plus je me renseignais, plus je réalisais que cette peur réelle
de la violence, de la discrimination et ce rejet
poussaient beaucoup de ces patients à se tourner vers l'alcool et la drogue.
J'ai aussi entendu ces histoires d'horreur
de patients qui ont besoin de soins médicaux,
comment ils sont traités,
et comment on ignore leurs besoins médicaux.
Maintenant, laissez-moi vous parler de Leah.
J'ai eu le plaisir de rencontrer Leah il y a quelques années.
C'est une femme qui a une épouse et un enfant.
Quand Leah est née, on lui a attribué le sexe masculin
mais depuis qu'elle est très jeune, elle sait qu'elle n'est pas un homme,
mais une femme.
Elle l'a caché à toutes ses connaissances et à elle-même,
en particulier à sa femme jusqu'à ses cinquante ans.
Elle n'en pouvait plus.
« Je ne peux plus vivre comme ça.
Je dois être honnête. »
Elle avait très peur de le dire à sa femme.
Et si sa femme lui disait :
« C'est inacceptable, je veux divorcer, va-t'en » ?
À sa grande surprise, sa femme a été très ouverte.
Elle lui a dit : « Je t'aime, que tu sois homme ou femme.
Je veux t'aider du mieux que je peux. »
Donc elles ont parlé,
et Leah a décidé qu'elle voulait faire une transition médicale,
et se faire évaluer pour un traitement hormonal substitutif
ou THS.
Elle a donc pris rendez-vous chez son médecin.
Le jour du rendez-vous, elle était en avance.
Elle a rempli tous les papiers,
écrit son nom correctement et patiemment attendu.
Le temps a passé et une infirmière l'a rappelée dans la salle d'examen.
Quand elle y est allée, elle a inspiré profondément,
et le médecin et l'infirmière sont entrés.
Elle a tendu la main au médecin et a dit : « Bonjour, je suis Leah. »
Le médecin l'a regardée, n'a pas serré sa main et a dit :
« Pourquoi êtes-vous ici ? »
Elle a de nouveau inspiré et a dit :
« Eh bien, je suis une femme transgenre.
Je l'ai toujours su, je l'ai caché à tout le monde,
mais je n'en peux plus.
Ma femme me soutient, j'en ai les moyens,
je dois faire la transition.
S'il vous plaît, regardez si je peux être candidate pour le THS. »
Le médecin a dit : « On ne peut rien faire maintenant.
Vous devez passer un test VIH. »
Elle n'arrivait pas à y croire.
Elle était furieuse.
Elle était en colère et déçue.
Si son médecin la traitait ainsi, comment feraient les autres ?
D'abord, il avait refusé de lui serrer la main,
et ensuite, quand elle lui avait dit qu'elle était transgenre,
il avait juste voulu qu'elle passe un test VIH et qu'elle s'en aille.
Il ne lui avait même pas posé d'autres questions.
Vous voyez, je comprends ce qu'a vécu Leah
car depuis le temps que j'œuvre avec la communauté,
j'entends tous les jours des mythes.
Par exemple :
tous les transgenres veulent faire la transition avec médicaments ou chirurgie ;
les transgenres sont malades, c'est un trouble mental ;
et ces gens ne sont pas des vrais hommes et femmes.
Ce sont des mythes, tout est faux.
Avec l'expansion et la maturation de cette communauté,
il faut que tous les professionnels de soins soient formés
pour répondre à leurs besoins médicaux.
En 2015, selon un sondage
72% des professionnels de santé
ne se sentaient pas assez bien informés
sur les besoins médicaux de la communauté LGBT.
Il y a un fossé énorme dans l'éducation et la formation.
Aujourd'hui, dans ce talk,
je veux offrir un nouveau mode de pensée à trois groupes :
les médecins, la communauté transgenre et, bien sûr, nous.
Mais, avant cela, je voudrais donner quelques définitions
qui vous aideront à mieux comprendre la notion d'identité de genre.
Vous avez du papier et un stylo, j'espère. Préparez-vous à noter.
Commençons par cette idée de système binaire.
Ça signifie que,
avant, on pensait qu'il n'y avait que masculin et féminin.
Compris ? Binaire ? D'accord ?
Mais on a fini par comprendre que c'était faux.
L'identité de genre est un spectre
avec la masculinité d'un côté
et la féminité de l'autre côté.
Le spectre des identités
couvre des identités comme non-conforme dans le genre,
affirmation de genre,
non-binaire,
bispirituels, trispirituels,
et les personnes intersexuées.
« Transgenre » est un terme générique
qui recouvre toutes ces identités différentes.
Mais aujourd'hui, considérez les transgenres
comme ceux dont le sexe à la naissance ne correspond pas
avec qui ils sont et leur perception d'eux-mêmes.
C'est très différent du sexe biologique.
L'identité de genre est la perception de soi.
Considérez que c'est ce qui est entre nos oreilles :
perception de soi, qui vous êtes.
Très différent du sexe biologique, pas vrai ?
Hormones, organes génitaux, chromosomes :
c'est ce qui est entre nos jambes.
Vous pensez peut-être : « Dr Kristie, je ne me suis jamais demandé qui j'étais.
Je sais que je suis un homme, ou une femme. »
D'accord. Vous savez qui vous êtes.
C'est pareil pour beaucoup d'individus transgenres.
Ils savent qui ils sont
avec la même conviction.
C'est important de savoir qu'il existe différents types d'identités,
et je m'identifie comme une femme cisgenre.
Pour tous ceux qui aiment bien épeler les mots,
« cis » s'écrit : C-I-S.
C'est un mot latin qui veut dire « du même côté que ».
À ma naissance,
le médecin m'a tendue à mes parents et a dit :
« C'est une fille. »
En se basant sur mes organes génitaux.
J'ai grandi dans une petite ville de campagne en Géorgie
et j'étais un vrai garçon manqué,
mais je n'ai jamais douté de mon genre.
J'ai toujours su que j'étais une fille,
quelle que soit mon enfance.
C'est très différent de quelqu'un qui est transgenre.
« Trans » est un mot latin qui veut dire « de l'autre côté » -
pensez aux lignes transcontinentales,
de l'autre côté de -
quelqu'un à qui on a assigné un sexe à sa naissance
et qui s'identifie de l'autre côté du spectre.
Un homme transgenre est quelqu'un qui est né avec un sexe féminin,
mais s'identifie, est, vit sa vie
en tant qu'homme.
L'inverse, dont on a discuté avant,
est une femme transgenre qui est née avec un sexe masculin
mais vit sa vie et s'identifie en tant que femme.
Il est important d'indiquer
que tous ceux qui ont une identité non-binaire
ne s'identifient pas au terme « transgenre ».
Pour que personne ne soit perdu, je veux parler de l'identité sexuelle,
ou orientation.
C'est tout simplement vers qui nous sommes attirés,
physiquement, émotionnellement, sexuellement, spirituellement.
Ça n'a rien à voir avec l'identité de genre.
Pour résumer rapidement avant de poursuivre :
identité de genre entre les oreilles,
sexe biologique entre les jambes,
et puis l'identité sexuelle, parfois on utilise le cœur,
mais c'est ici.
Trois spectres d'identité très différents.
En moyenne, un étudiant en médecine
passe cinq heures à apprendre les besoins médicaux des LGBT
quand ils sont en fac de médecine,
alors que nous savons qu'il y a des risques de santé spécifiques
à cette communauté.
Et on estime que 10 millions d'Américains adultes
s'identifient comme LGBT.
Beaucoup des médecins qui travaillent avec ces patients
apprennent avec l'expérience.
Ils résolvent les problèmes quand ils arrivent,
ou les patients passent leur temps
à tenter d'apprendre au médecin comment s'occuper d'eux.
Beaucoup de médecins n'osent pas se renseigner sur les identités de genre.
Certains ont l'impression que ça n'a rien à voir avec leurs soins
et d'autres ont peur de ne pas dire ce qu'il faut.
Beaucoup de médecins qui disent une chose déplacée
ou négative,
ne le font pas forcément pour se moquer ou par méchanceté,
ils n'ont peut-être juste jamais été formés à soigner ces individus.
Mais on ne peut plus trouver ça normal non plus.
Que se passe-t-il quand un homme transgenre -
petit rappel, c'est quelqu'un qui est né de sexe féminin
mais vit sa vie en tant qu'homme -
que se passe-t-il quand il a sa consultation gynécologique annuelle ?
La façon dont le médecin traite le patient
va donner le ton pour tout le cabinet.
Si le médecin utilise le prénom correct de cet homme, les bons pronoms,
le traite avec dignité et respect,
il est probable que le reste de l'équipe fera de même.
Voilà donc mes réflexions sur les médecins,
passons à la communauté transgenre.
Je parle de la peur,
mais vous savez tous qui a vraiment peur, pas vrai ?
C'est la communauté transgenre.
J'ai partagé l'histoire d'Anne -
son inquiétude d'entrer en désintox
de ne pas être respectée en tant que femme -
puis de Leah, qui avait peur de la réaction de son médecin.
Dès qu'il ne lui a pas serré la main
et a demandé un test VIH, ses craintes se sont confirmées.
Il faut que la communauté transgenre puisse
s'exprimer sur ses besoins médicaux.
Rester silencieux et prendre le premier traitement possible : c'est fini.
Si vous ne vous battez pas pour vos besoins médicaux,
personne ne le fera pour vous.
Et nous alors ?
Beaucoup, peut-être la semaine prochaine, ou dans deux mois,
vous avez un rendez-vous chez le médecin, non ?
Imaginons que vous alliez à votre rendez-vous
et que quand c'est fini,
vous vous sentez encore plus mal qu'en arrivant.
Et si vous vous sentiez rejeté par le médecin,
s'il ignorait vos besoins,
et si vous vous sentiez jugé ?
C'est ce qui arrive à beaucoup des 1,4 million de personnes transgenres
ici aux États-Unis
s'ils réussissent à avoir un rendez-vous.
Vous vous dites peut-être : « Pourquoi ça m'importe autant ?
Je ne suis pas transgenre. Je ne connais personne qui le soit.
Ça ne me concerne pas. »
Pensez-y de cette façon.
Un individu transgenre est humain,
comme vous et moi.
Il mérite des professionnels de santé compétents et formés,
Laissez-moi vous demander, merci de lever la main :
connaissez-vous ou avez-vous rencontré une personne transgenre,
non-conforme, sans genre, intersexuée, bispirituelle ou trispirituelle ?
Merci beaucoup à tous, merci.
Tous ceux qui n'ont pas levé la main,
très bientôt,
vous allez rencontrer
quelqu'un qui répond à une de ces identités, je vous le garantis.
Cette communauté est de plus en plus nombreuse.
Ce n'est pas tendance, ou la nouvelle mode.
Faire son coming-out est moins dangereux.
Les gens sont sensibilisés, il y a plus de visibilité.
Il y a plus de sécurité donc les gens révèlent leur vérité
comme jamais auparavant.
C'est pourquoi il est si important que le système de santé fasse de même
et s'assure que nos médecins et professionnels de santé soient formés
à traiter ces patients avec dignité et respect,
comme tout le monde.
Je me souviens de mon cours de littérature en première,
et un de mes professeurs préférés, M. McClain,
il nous a donné cette citation d'Héraclite qui m'accompagne encore.
Vous la connaissez peut-être.
« Rien n'est permanent, sauf le changement. »
Familier, pas vrai ?
Chacun doit faire face à des changements dans sa vie,
et quand c'est le cas,
il y a des décisions difficiles à prendre.
Allons-nous rester coincés, craintifs
et ne pas évoluer ?
Ou faire face avec courage,
évoluer, saisir l'opportunité de grandir ?
Chacun d'entre nous doit faire face à la nouveauté.
Qu'allez-vous faire ?
Allez-vous rester dans la peur,
ou grandir ?
J'invite chacun, les médecins, la communauté transgenre
et vous et moi
à affronter la peur ensemble
et avancer dans le meilleur des mondes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)